merci Laurence Rossignol de nous
accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure c'est matrice socialiste de
l'Oise vice-présidente du Sénat ont la
vue la motion de censure a donc été
rejetée hier à 9 mois près vous êtes
déçu ah oui une voix on peut se dire que
effectivement ils sont des fans de
quelques voies de quelques députés LR
qui aurait eu le sursaut et le courage
peut-être de se dire qu'ils pouvaient
mettre un terme à ce climat qui dans le
pays aujourd'hui est en train
d'inquiéter tout le monde et en fait
c'était ça l'enjeu de la motion de
censurière c'est peut-être savoir si on
pouvait remettre le pays sur pied dans
certains points de vue mettre fin à ce
conflit social qui traîne depuis un mois
et la responsabilité derrière non je
pense que la responsabilité principale
elle est sur Emmanuel Macron bien sûr
mais hier les députés LR avaient cette
question là est-ce que vous voulez
l'ordre parce qu'en fait beaucoup ont
dit on est le parti de l'ordre et comme
on est parti de l'ordre on vote pas
l'émotion de censure pour rétablir
l'ordre hier il fallait voter la motion
de censure c'était peut-être un peu
contre-intuitif pour eux mais je crois
qu'ils sont trompés de réponse sachant
que sur le fond beaucoup de députés à
l'air à l'image des sénateurs étaient
pour un report de l'âge de départ qu'ils
demandaient oui oui vous savez en
politique on peut avoir des grandes
ambitions on peut avoir des projets on
peut penser que ce serait bien de faire
ça puis à un moment donné le réel vous
amène à réviser vos certitudes et
j'entendais la première ministre sera
beaucoup attaqué Charles de Courson hier
sur le fait que il avait il aurait
changé d'avis mais c'est pas c'est pas
un plan de changer d'avis c'est mesurer
l'impact d'une réforme sur le pays et on
peut se dire bah voilà je pensais que
c'était bien de faire ça d'augmenter la
durée du travail pour autant étant donné
ce que ça provoque dans le pays je pense
qu'il serait raisonnable de revenir en
arrière et de ne pas imposer au pays
quelque chose dont il ne veut pas donc
les députés LR et tous ceux qui
auparavant auraient défendu
un recul de l'âge de la retraite et qui
aujourd'hui ont changé d'avis l'ont fait
parce qu'ils ont montré qu'ils étaient
pas dogmatiques contrairement au
président de la République qui quoi qui
se passe quoi qu'on lui dise quel que
soit le climat dans le pays continuent à
s'obstiner à vouloir passer cette
réforme dont plus personne ne comprend
d'ailleurs quelle est la signification
et l'enjeu puisqu'ils ont changé trois
fois d'explication au début c'était pour
faire une réforme juste ils nous ont
raconté des tas d'histoires j'en viens
pas sur les 1200 euros les 43 ans etc
ensuite c'est une réforme pour sauver le
régime de retraite et puis à la fin on a
aussi une réforme pour les marchés donc
on se dit la quelle était l'explication
véridique peut-être aucune probablement
aucune en fin de compte mais est-ce que
ce matin alors qu'hier la réforme a été
adoptée par le Parlement puisque Roger
de la motion censure signifiait adoption
du texte est-ce que vous ce matin vous
demandez encore son retrait bien sûr
vous savez moi j'ai pas oublié le CPE
que tout le monde a en tête ou le la
réforme a été retirée après la
promulgation de la loi bien sûr qu'on
demande son retrait bien sûr que la
manifestation la grande journée de
mobilisation de jeudi va être encore
très importante et nous allons utiliser
comme disait Jean-Jacques Goldman tous
les moyens y compris les moyens légaux
pour faire échec à cette réforme donc le
rythme le référendum d'initiative
parlementaire et puis d'autres parts le
recours au Conseil constitutionnel nous
ne lâcherons pas il n'a pas lâché nous
ne nagerons pas non plus on va
évidemment parler de tout ça mais est-ce
que vous demandez ce matin le départ
d'Elizabeth borne écoutez
Elisabeth borne
qui est-elle dans cette affaire à part
l'instrument de Sin d'Emmanuel Macron je
ne demande pas non plus le départ du
président de la République je demande je
ne sais pas si une question d'un autre
gouvernement frais autre chose est-ce
qu'il faut est-ce qu'il faut proposer
des arrangements entre la droite qui a
soutenu la réforme et puis en marche
enfin tout ça n'a en fin de compte
serait pas forcément la solution pour
vous je pense qu'ils y arriveront
inéluctablement ce gouvernement est
carbonisé la première ministre est aussi
j'entendais vous disiez il pour
l'instant le président de la République
consulte alors j'ai quand même levé la
tête je dis ah tiens il va rencontrer
enfin l'Inter syndicale pas du tout il
consulte sa présidente de l'Assemblée il
consulte ses députés il consulte ses
ministères l'entre-soi et Gérard et
Gérard Larcher parce que c'est le
président de du Sénat et peut-être aussi
parce que il a été d'un bon soutien dans
cette loi disons-le également mais en
fait il se consultent entre eux c'est
l'entre-soi macroniste d'une équipe qui
gouverne hors sol notre pays et qui
continue de se congratuler en elle-même
Emmanuel Macron doit prendre la parole
demain il doit s'exprimer devant les
Français il sera l'invité des trésors de
TF1 de France 2 qu'attendez-vous de lui
je ne sais pas ce que j'attendu le
retrait bien entendu à cet instant je ne
peux vous dire rien d'autre que le
retrait et puis peut-être
un peu d'empathie pour le pays moi
j'étais très frappé hier j’écoutais
discours de la première ministre j'ai
trouvé ça d'une violence politique assez
inédite elle n'a fait que
essorée ses adversaires politiques
tous ceux qui sont pas d'accord avec
elle ce après quoi elle a essayé de
mettre chacun devant ses contradictions
pas un mot pour le pays en fait ce qu'il
ne comprennent pas ce qui m'étonne dans
le macronisme c'est que l'impression ils
ont deux pôles un pôle qui est d'une
part les marchés alors ça ils
connaissent ils savaient exactement ce
que veulent les marchés l'autre pôle
c'est des petites histoires de la
politique la politique ayrie moi
j'appelle ça c'est à dire un tel qui va
peut-être se retourner ou peut-être
qu'il va nous soutenir la politique à 2
euros pas plus que ça et entre les deux
il y a le pays et ça il n'y connaît ce
rien et non pas d'histoire dans les
luttes ils ne savent pas ce que c'est
que le mouvement social je sais pas
quels sont les études qu'ils ont fait
mais dans leurs études apparemment ils
ont quand même zappé la formation sur
l'histoire du mouvement ouvrier et
d'éluses sociales et des acquis sociaux
ceci n'est pas dans leur champ et ils
ont mis ce pays à feu et à sang
aujourd'hui dans des conditions qui sont
les plus mauvaises un certain point de
vue dans le contexte dans lequel on est
aussi bien en France on sait qu'il y a
de la radicalité et on l'a vu avec la
fin des gilets jaunes pas le début au
début c'est un beau mouvement mon avis
après ce qui s'est passé à la fin on
sait que partout dans le monde
aujourd'hui la démocratie contestée les
gens ne pensent plus que la démocratie
est le meilleur des systèmes pour
répondre à leurs problèmes et le
président de la République accroît le
désamour pour la démocratie parce que au
bout de tout ça qu'est-ce qu'on en
déduit que ça sert à rien de voter
le seul vote qui compte c'est celui pour
le président de la République parce que
de toute façon à la fin il va tordre le
bras de tous les députés grâce à 1000 et
une technique de la Constitution et des
règlements des parlements donc à la fin
il y a qu'un seul vote qui compte c'est
celui du président de la République mais
ça c'est plus une démocratie c'est un
plébiscite permanent et aujourd'hui
puisqu'il est autant besoin de montrer
au pays que il gouverne tout et ben
qu'il aille devant le pays c'est le but
du référendum que nous demandons et
justement on va en parler puisque
effectivement vous continuez le combat
contre cette réforme des retraites la
gauche compte faire plusieurs recours on
voit tout ça avec notre journaliste
parlementaire Alex tout ça
[Musique]
bonjour Ariane bonjour Laurence
rossignols
saisir aujourd'hui le Conseil
constitutionnel pour essayer d'obtenir
la censure de la réforme des retraites
est-ce que c'est possible qu'il y a
plusieurs arguments qui laissent penser
que cette réforme des retraites pourrait
être toquée au moins partiellement par
le Conseil constitutionnel avec
plusieurs points à litigieux d'abord le
véhicule législatif le gouvernement a
choisi un budget de la Sécurité sociale
à rectificatif pour faire passer cette
réforme des retraites ce qui a limité le
temps de débat parlementaire à 50 jours
dans les deux chambres c'est le fameux
article 47 1 de la Constitution et cette
mesure avait déjà été critiquée par le
Conseil d'État ensuite certains points
du coup du texte n'ont pas de lien avec
un budget de la Sécurité sociale c'est
le cas de l'index sur l'emploi à des
seniors cette mesure elle pourrait être
balayée par les sages du Conseil
constitutionnel et puis lors du débat au
Sénat la droite sénatoriale et le
gouvernement ont utilisé de nombreux
leviers de procédures des articles de
règlement du Sénat des articles de la
Constitution pour accélérer les débats
ce qui fait espérer à gauche que ce
débat parlementaire soit à déclaré
insert par le Conseil constitutionnel
constitutionnel en tout cas une réforme
de retraite retoquée et bien la
présidente du groupe communiste au Sénat
il croit écoutez Eliane assassin il y a
plusieurs mesures de cette de cette
réforme des retraites qui n'a
strictement rien à voir avec un projet
de loi de financement la sécurité
sociale donc nous allons laisser le
Conseil constitutionnel donné son avis
sur ces sur ce point mais sur d'autres
aussi qui sont dans le texte donc oui
pour nous ce texte et illégique il est
illégitime parce que nous pensons que
constitutionnellement il est à côté des
clous et nous pensons qu'il est
illégitime parce qu'il n'a pas de
majorité dans le pays et Alex les
parlementaires de gauche veulent aussi
lancer un référendum d'initiative
partagée sur la réforme des retraites
mais le chemin ils l'ont mais oui l'idée
c'est d'obliger Emmanuel Macron à
organiser un référendum sur le report de
l'âge de départ à la retraite c'est
possible mais il y a plusieurs étapes à
passer première étape il faut qu'au
moins 185 parlementaires signent une
proposition de loi en faveur de ce
référendum alors ça c'est fait le texte
vient d'être déposé à l'Assemblée
nationale et valider deuxième étape plus
compliqué ce référendum doit être
soutenu par
4,87 millions de signatures de citoyens
les parlementaires de gauche auront 9
mois pour recueillir ces signatures
périodes pendant laquelle la réforme
peut être suspendue et une étape très
difficile avec par exemple le référendum
d'initiative partagé sur la
privatisation d'Aéroport de Paris qui
avait trébuché sur cette étape et il
avait recueilli qu'un million de
signatures même si c'était déjà un bon
un bon score on peut l'admettre et puis
la dernière étape ainsi ces signatures
citoyennes sont récoltées et bien le
président de la République doit
organiser ce référendum si jamais le
Parlement n'examine pas la proposition
de loi dans les six mois et s'il
Parlement examine le texte et bien cela
mettra un terme à la procédure de
référendum d'initiative partagée
Laurence Rossignol d'abord sur l'examen
par le Conseil constitutionnel de ces
recours déposés par la gauche et par le
rassemblement national est-ce que vous
pensez que cette réforme peut être
rotoquée
écoutez je pense que dans cette réforme
il y a beaucoup de vices et à tous les
sens du mot vice c'est à dire qu'il y a
une approche vicieuse de la part du
gouvernement de la procédure choisie et
puis il y a des vis de procédures
ensuite dans la manière dont les choses
se sont se sont faites pourquoi je dis
qu'il y a un vice parce que déjà choisir
un projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale rectificative pour une
réforme dont l'objet n'est pas des
incidences budgétaires sur les budgets
sociaux l'objet est de reporter l'âge de
la retraite déjà c'est un choix qui
était un choix et là je reviens sur le
premier sens du mot vicieux c'était
vicieux parce que le but était que le
débat soit court à l'Assemblée puisque
c'est un débat encadré dans le temps et
ensuite que le gouvernement puisse user
d'un 49-3 puisque l'usage des 49-3 est
illimité sur les textes financiers alors
qu'il est limité sur les autres les
autres projets de loi donc déjà il y a
ça première chose quand même que je
trouve qu'elle le conseille devra se
prononcer donc une fois qu'on a dit ça
il y a dans ce texte beaucoup d'articles
qui n'ont pas d'incidence financière sur
le budget de la Sécurité sociale 2023
qu'est-ce qu'ils font là voilà est-ce
que ce sont des cavaliers parce que nous
à chaque fois qu'on fait un amendement
on nous dit ah non cavalier vous ne
pouvez pas demander au Sénat discuter de
cet article de cette amendement c'est un
cavalier alors on va voir si dans cette
affaire là combien il y a de cavaliers
dans le
la loi enfin dernière chose
l'accumulation de toutes les procédures
toutes à l'Assemblée comme au Sénat
toutes les procédures constitutionnelles
et celles dérèglement qui visent toutes
à éteindre le débat et ce qui fait qu'à
l'Assemblée le texte n'a pas été voté en
première lecture comme on le sait et
qu'au Sénat il a été ensuite par une
procédure de votre bloqué qui a empêché
que les amendements de l'opposition
soient soumis au vote du Sénat et puis
s'être discuté et enfin une commission
mixte paritaire qui a travaillé sur d'un
côté un texte non adopté dans une des
chambres à l'Assemblée et de l'autre un
texte adopté sans respect du droit
d'amendement des sénateurs donc
effectivement le Conseil constitutionnel
a de quoi réfléchir et censurer mais
vous espérez une censure totale
dis-moi j'espère une censure suffisante
pour que le gouvernement soit obligé de
reculer sur l'allongement de le report
de l'âge de la retraite c'est le sujet
il n'y a qu'un seul sujet dans cette
affaire les gens ne peuvent pas
travailler deux ans de plus comme le
gouvernement leur demande voilà je ne
sais le seul sujet et je voudrais dire
une chose profiter que je suis chez vous
on a entendu beaucoup beaucoup
d'arguides la part de du gouvernement en
particulier sauver le régime de retraite
rétablir les finances publiques
satisfaire les marchés savez-vous est-ce
que les gens qui nous écoutent savent
que depuis 2017 ce gouvernement a
priver les finances publiques de 500
milliards d'euros depuis 2017 le cumulé
de tous les cadeaux fiscaux qu'ils ont
fait de tous les allègements d'impôts
pour les plus riches c'est 500 milliards
d'argent public en moins beaucoup pour
les plus riches quand même beaucoup
beaucoup pour les plus riches parce que
les plus riches on voit bien on voit
nettement dans les dans les enquêtes
comment les plus riches ont vu leurs
revenus s'accroître et leur patrimoine
s'accroître en revanche on voit pas de
progrès de pouvoir d'achat chez les
autres donc infini c'est bien pour les
plus riches mais surtout c'est que ça
dévitalisé assécher les services publics
et les services publics c'est le
patrimoine de ceux qui n'en n'ont pas
c'est ce que les moins riches ont pour
accéder à la santé à l'école à la
justice donc ce gouvernement qui vient
nous expliquer qu'il faut de l'argent
500 milliards d'euros de cadeaux depuis
2017 je crois que
s'ils ont pas compris que leur politique
les Français n'en veulent plus parce
qu'elle est profondément injuste c'est
ça qui est c'est ça aujourd'hui qui met
les gens dans la rue c'est la justice
globale de la politique macroniste sur
l'effet indominitiative partagée on l'a
vu le chemin est très long pour pouvoir
organiser ce référendum sur la réforme
des retraites est-ce que vous pensez
pouvoir y arriver ou est-ce que
l'objectif c'est simplement de retarder
l'application de cette réforme non non
je pense que les 4,9 millions de
signatures ils sont atteignables vous
disiez un instant à DESPER on avait fait
un million la marche était encore haute
mais enfin quand même un million sur ADP
qui concerne pas tout le monde c'était
déjà pas mal donc il y a une
disponibilité là aujourd'hui avec 93%
des salariés hostiles à la loi cette
Français sur 10 hostile à la Loire si on
travaille bien et on n'est pas tout seul
en plus il y a des relais une
orientation syndicale tout le monde peut
un moment donné venir soutenir et
nourrir les 4000,9 millions de
signatures nécessaires je crois vraiment
que c'est possible d'y arriver Jean-Luc
Mélenchon il appelle la censure
populaire lui vous partagez cette
expression et cet appel
c'est un effet c'est un effet de
communication on peut pas dire aux gens
aujourd'hui ben voilà c'est fini
l'histoire est terminée le gouvernement
a fait le 49-3 il a manqué 9 voix donc
maintenant vous pouvez retourner chez
vous et vous préparer à travailler deux
ans de plus on peut pas dire ça et on
voit bien que de toute façon il y a de
la mobilisation elle est là elle va pas
elle ne va pas s'arrêter et vous
craignez qu'elle sera du calice qui a
dégénère qu'elle dégénère pardon qui est
beaucoup de violence bien sûr que je
crains que ça que les mobilisations
connaissent des moments de
radicalisation des moments de violence
pour autant pour autant ce n'est pas une
raison suffisante pour cesser la
mobilisation voilà ça c'est une le
gouvernement a fait le choix de la
radicalisation moi je leur ai posé la
question pendant le débat au Sénat et
après qu'est-ce que vous voulez le
pourrissement la radicalisation c'est
soit qu'ils ont fait on fait pas une
réforme des retraites sans à la CFDT je
crois de ça comme ça depuis le début
donc le choix qu'ils ont fait c'est de
marginaliser les organisations
syndicales représentatives et en faisant
ça bien entendu qu'il laisse un champ à
la radicalisation et à des il y a des
manifestations plus violentes et ils
espèrent qu'avec ça ils vont nous faire
reculer dans certains points de vue dans
notre détermination et qu'on va dire ah
bah non on sous prétexte que il peut y
avoir d'ici là des événements plus plus
tendus il faut pas se mobiliser c'est un
chantage le gouvernement fait du
chantage sur le mouvement social et
chantage là on accepte pas merci Alex à
tout à l'heure on va parler des
conséquences sur les républicains
et on va voir les conséquences de ce
mouvement dans votre département de
l'Oise avec nos partenaires de la presse
régionale on retrouve Jean-Marc
chevaucher bonjour Jean-Marc merci
beaucoup d'être avec son rédacteur en
chef adjoint au Courrier Picard et
Jean-Marc vous allez revenir justement
sur cette réforme des retraites et les
répercussions sur la politique locale
et bien oui dans l'Oise la recomposition
politique est peut-être déjà en marche
puisque on sait surtout à droite on sait
qu'Eric verte est devenu macroniste hier
un des rares députés des républicains
avoir voté les deux motions de censure
et Maximino députés de l'Oise les
républicains qui a voté également la
motion du rassemblement national alors
ma question pour Laurence Rossignol à
travers ce qui s'est passé hier et les
répercussions que ça dans votre
département est-ce que vous analysez
cela aussi comme une recomposition de la
droite dans l'Oise qui qui peut aller
jusqu'à l'extrême droite entre ce qui
s'est passé avec Éric woert qui est
devenu macroniste je le disais et Maxime
minot qui a voté hier pour la pour la
motion du rassemblement national
département d'Oise est un département
dans lequel leur rassemblement national
est fort depuis longtemps depuis déjà
moins 20 ans fondational faisait déjà
des gros scores il continue on a trois
députés RN dans ce département alors que
c'est un département populaire c'est un
département industriel historiquement ça
département de salariés beaucoup de gens
de son travail aussi dans le tertiaire
en Île-de-France et c'est un département
avec des zones urbaines denses et puis
beaucoup beaucoup de villages et
effectivement le RN fait des scores
importants dans les villages dans le
département j'avais pas repéré que
Maxime minot avait aussi voté la
deuxième motion de censure celle du
rassemblement national je pense qu'il a
eu tort mais je sais que dans notre
département la porosité entre la droite
et l'extrême droite n'est pas nouvelle
je vous rappelle quand même que en
1998 si ma mémoire est bonne à peu de
choses près au moment où
la région était dirigée par Charlesbourg
Charlesbourg avait été élu par une
alliance entre la droite traditionnelle
et le Front national de l'époque donc à
une histoire dans ce département de
porosité il faut surveiller ça avec
beaucoup de beaucoup de vigilance et
j'ajoute quand même que les sénateurs LR
on revanche ont voté la
réforme des retraites
tous donc à la droite est aussi divisée
entre ces élus dans le département
certains votent la motion de censure et
d'autres votent la réforme c'est un peu
à l'image de ce qui attend les
républicains mais ce département nous
enfin oui m'inquiète parce que
effectivement vous vous manifestez bien
il y a des recompositions possibles
elle rassemblement national au-delà de
l'Oise le rassemblement national sort
gagnant de cette séquence pour vous
écoutez je ne sais pas
je ne sais pas si le rassemblement
national sans gagnant de cette séquence
moi j'ai fait toutes les manifestations
pas dans toute la France j'ai fait dans
mon département Compiègne à Beauvais
département dont on disait il y a un
instant que il y a un terreau favorable
au vote et Rennes j'ai ce que j'ai vu
dans les manifestations c'est pas des
gens qui se reconnaissaient dans l'URN
mais puisque vous posez la question je
ferai quand même attirer l'attention sur
ce qui nous attend dans les semaines qui
vient après cette séquence désastreuse
dans lequel le pays ressort amer humilié
le gouvernement a choisi de mettre comme
prochain texte à l'ordre du jour
l'immigration
l'immigration c'est un sujet qui est un
sujet pour le rassemblement national de
facile parce que ça tient en trois
phrases dehors les immigrés en trois
mots de les immigrés or c'est un sujet
éminemment plus complexe que ça et après
cette séquence où le pays sort
totalement désemparé on donne le
gouvernement donne au rassemblement
national un sujet sur lequel il va
pouvoir caracoler se balader avec ces
discours simplicistes sur l'immigration
ça veut dire qu'on va donner au
rassemblement national la possibilité de
désigner des boucs émissaires dans un
moment où les gens vont mal je trouve
que de la part du gouvernement c'est
irresponsable
et je lui demande de retirer de l'ordre
du jour du Parlement ce texte sur
l'immigration qui va polluer et en
puanter le débat politique pendant
encore un long moment voilà 6
gouvernement veut réellement défendre la
démocratie et bien il retire le texte
sur l'immigration merci Jean-Marc
chevaucher merci d'avoir été avec nous
la une du Courrier Picard dans son
édition de l'Oise 9 voix et 64 ans c'est
à la Une de votre journal merci beaucoup
Jean-Marc chevaucher on va parler avant
de se quitter le rang social d'un texte
qui est examiné aujourd'hui au Sénat
venu de l'Assemblée c'est un texte qui
vise à mieux protéger les enfants
victimes de violences intrafamiliale il
rend notamment systématique plus
systématique en tout cas le retrait de
l'autorité parentale notamment en cas
d'agression sexuelle incestueuse est-ce
que ce texte va assez loin pour vous
alors il y avait ce texte est un bon
texte et je remercie ma collègue
Isabelle Santiago d'aller voir fait
adopter à l'Assemblée nationale il y
avait deux options soit on vote le texte
conforme au Sénat et il est tout de
suite mis en oeuvre soit c'est pas le
cas et on va encore perdre du temps donc
à partir du moment où visiblement la
rapporteur a pas voulu que ce texte soit
mis en application rapidement
déposer des amendements je peux me
permettre de dire que à mon sens il faut
aller beaucoup plus loin je vais vous
dire tous les jours tous les jours je
reçois des appels des des mails de
femmes donc séparer leur conjoint et du
père de leurs enfants dont les enfants
subissent des agressions sexuelles chez
le père pendant les week-ends de garde
chez le père et les juges ne les ne les
écoutent pas ne les croient pas ni les
maires ni les enfants de femmes qui sont
désespérées vous regardez vous pouvez
vous donner 10 cas comme ça y compris
une femme connue célèbre reconnu pour
leurs talents dans un certain nombre
d'activités dans ce pays et qui sont en
buts à une une incompréhension et une
suspicion de la justice qui sont
obligées de renvoyer leurs enfants tous
les week-ends chez un père qui les
maltraite des gamins qui rentrent et qui
racontent des choses épouvantables qui
ne sont connues j'ose même pas pour vous
dire ce que les enfants racontent à ce
moment-là il y a toujours un expert
psychologique psychiatrique qui arrive
et qui dit la mère manipule l'enfant
l'enfant affabulle la sexualité chez
l'enfant est un sujet de fantasme
résultat les enfants et de retourner
chez le père les mers sont désespérés un
certain nombre d'entre elles quitte le
territoire avec leurs gamins pour les
protéger et contre ça nous ne faisons
pas assez nous ne faisons rien donc la
proposition doit être Santiago est une
bonne proposition de loi et puis je veux
dire une deuxième chose sur la procédure
législative on y revient tous les tous
les tous les ans on a un nouveau texte
pour corriger les insuffisances du
suivant depuis 2017 on en est au
quatrième un moment donné faut prendre
les mesures nécessaires c'est du travail
de gribouille ce qu'on fait là merci
Laurence Rossignol et cet après-midi que
le Sénat examinera ce texte merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité dans
20 minutes dans le club des territoires
on viendra sur le vote de cette notion
de censure qui a échoué à 9 mois près
analyse à suivre dans le club et on en
parle tout de suite avec notre chaîne
invité François-Xavier Bellamy